- [Donald] I just wanna find 11,780 votes.
- Well, it took some time,
but it looks like we finally
found some voter fraud.
We're only a couple of days into 2021
and there is already a new Trump tape.
- [Donald] I have to find 12,000 votes
and I have them times a lot,
and therefore I won the state.
- It's been just about a
year since President Trump
made the perfect phone call to Ukraine,
where he attempted to
leverage over $400 million
in American taxpayer aid to Ukraine.
- That call was perfect. It
couldn't have been nicer.
- In an attempt to get help
against his main political
rival, Joe Biden,
but it appears that President Trump
is not done with the 2020 election.
Now, The Washington Post
has obtained bombshell audio
of over one-hour-long phone call
between on the one hand, President Trump,
Mark Meadows and a
lawyer for the president,
Cleta Mitchell of the
firm Foley & Lardner,
and on the other hand,
Georgia's Secretary of
State, Brad Raffensperger,
and Secretary of State
General Counsel, Ryan Germany.
And the parties, for over an hour,
discussed the Georgia election.
And during this call,
President Trump, shall we say,
expresses his extreme concern
about the numbers in Georgia
that the certified
election results have gone
for Joe Biden, the president elect.
And on the other hand,
Georgia's Secretary of State,
Brad Raffensperger, says
that the numbers are correct,
that there was no impropriety
and that they are very
confident in those numbers
and that the information
the president has is at best incorrect.
But our question for today
is whether the newest leaked audio
has put President Trump in
criminal jeopardy or not.
Now, I'm not going to go
into whether you can indict
a sitting president, because
we've talked about that
a million times on this channel.
And also President Trump
is not going to be the sitting
president for very long.
Also, let's not get bogged down
in whether he can pardon himself.
Moving on.
And not surprisingly,
already a number of
right-wing outlets are saying
that the crime is not
the phone call itself,
but the fact that someone would dare
to leak a non-private phone call
with the president of the United States.
Though I think those arguments,
not only are they made in bad faith,
but here they don't hold water
because on the morning
that the tape was released,
President Trump tweeted out,
"I spoke to Secretary of State
Brad Raffensperger yesterday
about Fulton County and
voter fraud in Georgia.
He was unwilling or
unable to answer questions
such as the ballots under the table scam,
ballot destruction, out-of-state voters,
dead voters, and more.
He has no clue!"
To which Raffensperger responded.
- There was no agreement,
and we didn't know what the
purpose of the call really was.
I assumed it was about
the November election,
really, Wednesday.
If President Trump wouldn't
have tweeted out anything
and would have stayed silent,
we would have stayed silent as well.
- And some people are claiming
that this is a confidential
settlement conference
regarding litigation.
And while there is such a thing
as confidential settlement agreements,
I've participated in many of them,
the thing is if you disclose
the content of that conference,
then arguably you have waived
your privilege to that content.
So it's likely that even
if privilege attached,
which I don't think would be the case
in this particular phone call,
arguably the president has waived
any claims of privilege here.
So what's the big deal
about this phone call?
- [Donald] The people
in the country are angry
and there's nothing wrong with saying
that you've recalculated.
- Well, actually there
could be a lot wrong
with saying that you recalculated
if you haven't actually recalculated,
if you're not allowed to recalculate,
if you recalculate for
pre-textual reasons,
or if you use the recalculation
to change the numbers inappropriately.
There's a lot that can be an issue here.
So let's start with Georgia state law.
The first part of Georgia
Code Section 21-2-562
deals with fraudulent entries,
unlawful alteration or
destruction of entries,
unlawful removal of documents
and neglect or refusal
to deliver documents.
It's obviously against Georgia law
to falsify documents or
records in connection
with an election or to
make any false entries.
And then there's Georgia
Code Section 21-2-576,
destroying or defacing or
delaying delivery of ballots.
Any person who willfully destroys
or defaces any ballot or
willfully delays the delivery
of any ballots shall be
guilty of a misdemeanor.
Then there's Section 45-11-1,
offenses involving public records,
documents, or other items.
It's against Georgia
law for public officials
to falsify any record
related to their office.
And then there's Section 21-2-597,
intentional interference with performance
of election duties.
Under Georgia law,
any person who intentionally
interferes with,
hinders or delays or
attempts to interfere with,
hinder or delay any other person
in the performance of any
act or duty authorized
or imposed by this chapter shall
be guilty of a misdemeanor.
And that refers to the election duties
of election-related officials in Georgia.
And then there's Section 21-2-604,
good old fashioned criminal solicitation
to commit election fraud.
And the important thing to note
in terms of this solicitation defense
which is actually the case
with most solicitation crimes,
is that it's not a defense that the person
you solicited did not take the bait.
And those are just the obvious
Georgia state-related election crimes.
Then there's a whole swath
of federal law related to elections.
The Department of Justice
guidance on federal prosecutions
for voter fraud states that the following
are prosecutable election crimes.
Quote, malfeasance by election officials
acting under color of law,
such as diluting valid
ballots with invalid ones,
so-called ballot box stuffing,
rendering false vote tabulations,
or preventing valid voter
registrations or votes
from being given effect in any election,
as well as in elections
where federal candidates
are on the ballot.
Now, 18 U.S.C. Sections 241 and 242,
are the civil rights conspiracy statutes.
Section 241 states,
if two or more persons conspire to injure,
oppress, threaten or intimidate
any person in any state
in the free exercise or
enjoyment of any right
or privilege secured to
him by the Constitution
or laws of the United States
or because of his having
so exercised the same, they
shall be fined under this title
or imprisoned not more
than 10 years, or both.
And the next section, 242,
makes it a crime for any person acting
under color of law, statute
ordinance regulation
or custom to willfully deprive
or cause to be deprived
from any person those rights,
privileges or immunities
secured or protected
by the Constitution and the
laws of the United States.
That includes depriving people
of their right to vote and have
their vote properly counted.
And then the other most
likely applicable federal law
would be the National
Voter Registration Act,
now codified as 52 U.S.C. 2501,
which also makes it illegal
for election officials to commit fraud,
specifically anyone who knowingly
and willfully deprives,
defrauds or attempts to deprive or defraud
the residents of a state
of a fair and impartially
conducted election process
by the procurement, casting
or tabulation of ballots
that are known by the person
to be materially false,
fictitious or fraudulent under the laws
of the state in which
the election is held.
So those are the state and federal laws
that are most likely to apply
in this particular situation.
So the question is, do
they actually apply?
Did the president actually violate
one of these criminal
election-related statutes?
Well, as we've discussed
many times on this channel,
often criminality requires
a specific mental state,
a mens rea, and this case is no different.
Sometimes the same actual
physical conduct can be criminal
depending on the particular
mental state that someone had.
And the criminal justice system
is actually very, very concerned
with the intent that someone has.
And here, most of the state
and federal election crimes
require mental states
of either willfulness or intentionality.
And those carry very specific meanings
in the world of criminal law.
Willfulness is generally defined
as meaning the prosecutor must prove
beyond a reasonable doubt
that the defendant knew
that their conduct was
unlawful and intended
to do something that the law forbids.
That is that they acted with a purpose
to disobey or disregard the law.
Now, many states define willfulness
and intentionality slightly differently.
It's a very ambiguous term
within the world of criminal law.
That's actually why people have tried
to adopt what's called a model penal code,
but we'll save that for another day.
Now, I looked and I
couldn't find how Georgia
defines or construes its
willfulness requirement
in the context of these
election law violations.
But you will notice
that the federal laws also use
the willfulness requirement.
And there is some case law with respect
to the federal laws here.
For President Trump to be convicted
under Section 242, for example,
a prosecutor would have
to show three elements
that he acted under color of
law, that he acted willfully,
and that he deprived or
attempted to deprive someone
of the rights of the
constitution or federal law.
And courts have interpreted Section 242
to impose a specific intent requirement.
The prosecutor would need to
show that the president acted
with a specific intent to deprive someone
of a constitutional right
or with an open defiance
or in reckless disregard of
a constitutional requirement.
And as always, the criminal justice system
looks to the context and
circumstantial evidence
to determine someone's mental state,
because no one can read minds.
And recall that circumstantial
evidence isn't weak,
it's often the strongest
evidence that we have.
So let's look to the call itself
and see what a prosecutor and
a defense attorney would argue
in the context of this call
and the general election.
Now, arguably President
Trump's greatest exposure
is probably under the solicitation laws.
President Trump seemingly
asked Brad Raffensperger
not to count legal votes.
He asked him to find the exact number
of votes needed to overturn the result.
Just one more than Joe
Biden got would do it.
In one portion of the call,
President Trump seemingly accuses
both Brad Raffensperger
and the General Counsel
for the Secretary of State, Ryan Germany,
of engaging in criminal conduct.
- [Donald] And you're
gonna find that they are,
which is totally illegal.
It's more illegal for
you than it is for them
because you know what they did
and you're not reporting it.
That's a criminal offense.
And you can't let that happen.
That's a big risk to you
and to Ryan, your lawyer.
That's a big risk.
- A threat that comes from the president
of the United States
who of course controls
the Department of Justice.
He says that it's criminal
and you can't let that happen.
It's a risk.
It's a big risk to both
Raffensperger and Germany.
When the president of the United States
says that you're engaging
in criminal conduct,
that carries a different kind of weight
than when you're just
Joe Schmo on the street.
And then right after
that particular section
where he's saying that
the Georgia officials
have engaged in criminal conduct,
he then goes on to say that
he just wants 11,780 votes.
- [Donald] You know, I mean,
I'm notifying you that
you're letting it happen.
So look, all I wanna do is this,
I just wanna find 11,780 votes,
which is one more than we have
because we won the state.
- And that number could
be incredibly important
because he's not saying he wants all
of the fraudulently cast
ballots or that he wants all
of the incorrectly cast ballots
to be reversed in his favor.
He wants specifically one more vote
than Joe Biden won the state by.
President Trump in many
different spots says
that Joe Biden ostensibly
has won Georgia by 11,779.
Thus President Trump wants
just one more than that.
And that could go a long way
towards establishing the mens rea
of the criminality that
he knows that the numbers
are false and that he just
wants one single vote more.
He doesn't care exactly how many he gets
as long as he beats Joe Biden.
And then arguably in
almost the next sentence,
he says that he doesn't exactly
care how Georgia does it.
Call it a mistake, call
it a recalculation,
just do it and flip the state.
- [Donald] And flipping the
state is a great testament
to our country because it's a
testament that they can admit
to a mistake or whatever
you wanna call it.
If it was a mistake, I don't know.
A lot of people think it wasn't a mistake,
it was much more criminal than that.
- And then President
Trump seemingly goes on
to cajole the Georgia officials
in speak that literally
sounds like a mobster.
- [Donald] So what are
we gonna do here, folks?
I only need 11,000 votes.
Fellas, I need 11,000
votes. Give me a break.
You know, we have that in spades already.
- "What are we gonna do,
fellas? Give me a break.
We have it in spades already."
I mean, he really does seem
like he watched a bunch
of 1940s gangster movies.
And President Trump just can't even fathom
why a Republican official in Georgia
wouldn't be trying to
do everything possible
to give the election to
a Republican president.
- [Donald] Why don't you
wanna find this, Ryan?
What's wrong with you?
I heard your lawyer is
very difficult actually,
but I'm sure you're a good lawyer.
You have a nice last name.
But I'm just curious
why do you keep fighting this thing?
It just doesn't make sense.
- And then President Trump goes on to say
that they need to reexamine
the election results
but they need to reexamine it
with people that want to find the answers,
seemingly implying that
they should use people
who were in on the fix and
will actually flip the results.
- [Donald] So tell me,
Brad, what are we gonna do?
We won the election and it's not fair
to take it away from us like this.
And it's gonna be very
costly in many ways.
And I think you have to say
that you're gonna reexamine it.
And you can reexamine it,
but reexamine it with people
that wanna find answers,
not people that don't wanna find answers.
- So assuming that the actual
acts here rise to the level
of the various election crimes
that we discussed and frankly,
getting a Secretary of State
to literally change the
votes to turn an outcome
probably qualifies for a lot of the things
that we previously talked about.
A prosecutor would argue
that these statements show
that President Trump does have
the requisite mental
state for these crimes.
And there is a specific
intent to violate the law
and engage in criminality.
A prosecutor would say President Trump
is going after exactly the number of votes
that's needed to flip the state,
that he's recognizing that the information
is against him and that he
doesn't seriously believe
that he actually won the state,
that he is threatening the officials
in charge of the election
results in Georgia.
Not only that, but later on in the tapes,
he talks about how all the
good things will happen
to Raffensperger and Germany
if they do flip the state in his favor.
So he's offering both carrots
and sticks to change the results.
And it appears that he's
single-mindedly focused
on the outcome rather than the process.
On the other hand, a defense attorney
for President Trump would
argue based on the context
of the call and on the explicit
language of the call itself
that President Trump did
not engage in criminality.
That the statements that
we just talked about
make sense in context.
And certainly everyone would agree
that President Trump never explicitly said
invent fake votes so that
he wins the election.
It appears that throughout the call,
President Trump has an honest belief,
a subjective honest belief that may
or may not comport with objective reality,
but nonetheless an honest belief
that there was fraud in Georgia.
- [Donald] The bottom
line is many, many times,
the 11,779 margin that
they said we lost by,
we had vast, I mean, the
state is in turmoil over this,
and I know you would like
to get to the bottom of it.
- He seems fixated by it.
He seems to believe everything
that the social media
or as he calls it, the Trump media.
He says he does not watch social media,
he watches Trump media,
but he appears to believe everything
that those sources are saying.
- [Donald] And also that
Dominion took out machines.
That Dominion is really moving fast
to get rid of their machinery.
Do you know anything about that?
Because that's illegal.
- [Ryan] This is Ryan Germany.
No, Dominion has not moved any machinery
out of Fulton County.
We're having an election on Tuesday.
- [Donald] Have they moved the inner parts
of the machines and replaced
them with other parts?
- [Ryan] No.
- [Donald] Are you sure, Ryan?
- [Ryan] I'm sure, I'm
sure, Mr. President.
- It's total nonsense, but he
seems to actually believe it.
So in the context of that,
of the Trump news media,
and President Trump is looking
into ways of addressing the fraud
that he honestly believes took place.
And yes, President Trump
referred to the number 11,780
which is a very convenient
number for the president.
That's a number that would flip Georgia.
But really, throughout the call,
President Trump is referring to lots
of different numbers related
to the claimed election fraud.
At some times talking about
300,000 mysterious ballots
or quote, massive numbers
far greater than the 11,779.
Or he says that accurate numbers
would include more than
fifties of thousands.
He's convinced that there are far more
than the number of votes
necessary for him to win,
and he's just concerned
about finding enough.
At one point he says he doesn't want to go
after Dominion because he doesn't need to,
because there are all these other votes
that were fraudulently cast
that total far more than 12,000.
So therefore they don't even need
to get into the Dominion thing.
And at the same time,
the president's lawyer,
Cleta Mitchell of Foley & Lardner
says that what they're trying to get
is the data from Georgia,
that Georgia for legal
and privacy reasons,
has not disclosed a lot
of the election-related data to them,
so they actually can't check some
of these fraud-related
claims and they simply
want the data to be
able to make that check,
though that may seemingly
be illegal in and of itself.
- [Cleta] I think what president's saying
and what we've been trying
to do is to say, look,
the court is not acting on our petition.
They haven't even assigned a judge,
but the people of Georgia and the people
of America have a right
to know the answers
and you have data and records
that we don't have access to.
- And then unfortunately
there's the additional problem
that a lot of the president's thoughts
are completely inchoate.
The problem is the
president has brain worms.
- Brain worms.
- At one point in the call, he
says that he literally thinks
that he won every state in the country.
- [Donald] Oh, every single state.
We won every state,
we won every State House in the country.
- So when someone's head is
filled with complete nonsense,
that actually has a big effect in terms
of trying to prove a subjective,
specific intent crime.
So a prosecutor would
say that you have to read
between the lines, you have to
read the subtext to the text
and that just like no mafia don
would ever say explicitly
commit the crime itself.
It's meant through implication.
And that you have to look at the leverage
and the pressure that someone is putting
on another person to commit a crime.
While a defense attorney would say
this is just someone that
is extremely concerned
about the election who
has honest, if crazy,
beliefs about that election
and that they're just trying
to explore the legal avenues
to come to the outcome that
they believe is the right one.
And then finally there is the question
of apart from the potential
criminality itself,
could this behavior be impeachable,
just the implication
of the context itself?
And the answer to that
is almost certainly yes.
Congress has wide discretion to impeach
and the Senate to remove
based on impropriety.
And it's hard to believe that even
if the phone call itself was not criminal,
that based on the context
and the implications that the president
either knew or should have known
that what he was doing was
improper in the context
of a democratic republic and
thus it's removable conduct.
But it appears that President
Trump finally got his wish.
He finally found the election
fraud that he was looking for.
And when Susan Collins
said that she thought
that President Trump
had learned his lesson
from the last perfect phone
call and the last impeachment,
it appears that he did learn a lesson
that he should just do it again.
But on the other hand,
it appears that the Democratic member
of the Georgia State Election Board
has formally asked the
Georgia Secretary of State
to open an investigation into
possible criminal violations
by President Trump
based on the phone call.
So it's anyone's guess as
to what's going to happen
to President Trump as a
result of this phone call,
both while he's in office and
eventually when he leaves.